dies von nur 600 nun ist klar
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
der stadtgarten re zürich zu der neue
serie mit fortsetzungsgeschichte aus dem
topf redaktion jedes jahr produziert
schweizer fernsehen mehrere dutzend
reporter und dokfilm offizielle
geschichte von menschen mit
schicksalsschlägen abenteuerreise plan
erfolg und misserfolg und möchte
natürlich müssen wir gott sei nichts
weiter nach drehschluss durch zum
beispiel der engagiert die landratsamt
wurde sie doch der willibald die wo
immer für menschen toxisch tauchen nach
jorio russ mit collected bienenschwarm
der hätte lieber die begleitet mit der
kamera ist mit durchgang hätten
beobachtet ist in der praxis nicht sehen
was für eine spannende und
abwechslungsreiche beruf der bahn die
hat habe ich mir überlegt warum
entscheidet sich einig nicht mehr junge
männer und frauen dafür umsatz werde
bei aller bescheidenheit
dieser film handelt von nichts weniger
als dem ganzen leben und seinen manchmal
schmerzlichen momenten
[Musik]
wir sind mit doktor baldi fachmann für
menschliches leiden unterwegs
[Musik]
wieder einmal steht ein hausbesuch an
bei franz und josephine baumeler einem
alleinstehenden ehepaar
[Musik]
baumann es einst alphirten leben seit
jahrzehnten in diesem haus franz wurde
hier geboren
haushund finow ergänzt die gemeinschaft
franz ist 90 hat
sagt jetzt lehnen ihn dir sonst den
haushalt schmeißt heftige hüftschmerzen
durch die runde dass er hier vermerkt
sind nicht des doktors lieblinge
vielleicht ein ungünstiger zug für einen
landarzt
jetzt mache ich nicht so spritzig
so jetzt machen wir grüne mittelstrecke
rocky auto zwar wieder besser
so der bürgerstiftung
und china
[Musik]
josefine baum oder sie ist 84 und hat
zucker seit 55 jahren ist sie mit franz
verheiratet doktor baldi kommt häufig zu
ihnen auf hausbesuch und
[Musik]
wie immer steckt frau baumann zum
abschluss den herrn doktor eine tafel
schokolade zu
[Musik]
mitten im dorf entlebuch die praxis von
doktor ball
hier in diesen räumen die vor halb acht
von praxisassistentin regula
aufgeschlossen werden machen wir wären
zwei wochen station der landarzt heißt
es figuriere auf der liste der bedrohten
arten jetzt wo es sie noch gibt wollen
wir aus seinem alltag berichten
wie klingen bei ihm die geschichten die
das leben schreibt
wir dürfen fast überall filmen wir tun
es nicht bei gynäkologischen untersuchen
und heiklen themen wie alkoholismus
sonst sind wir dabei vom baby schrei bis
zum seufzer des alters
nach halb acht treffen karin und janine
zwei weitere praxis mitarbeiterinnen ein
gleich neben der praxis ist die wohnung
von doktor baldi sein arbeitsbeginn ist
um 8 letzte nacht war allerdings noch um
2 uhr unterwegs wegen eines todesfalls
die praxis ist jetzt stark bereits die
ersten patienten warten
will baldi praktiziert seit 15 jahren in
entlebuch der 56 jährige zürcher mit
italienischen wurzeln arbeitet viel gut
und gerne zwölf stunden täglich
punkt 8 wie immer auftritt doktor baldi
gleich werden wir mittendrin sein
mitten im prallen leben mit seinen
risiken und nebenwirkungen
und wie jeden tag bricht eine geballte
ladung leiden über den arzt
dass ich da so
[Gelächter]
marie koch weiter um bekannte berühren
marie ist 61 und siegel sie
bewirtschaftet einen großen bauernhof
allein
marie hatte einen zwischenfall im stall
eine ihre kühe stieß ihr die hirne in
den rücken seither peinigen sie
schmerzen die einfach nicht abflauen
wollen verdacht gebrochene rippen fester
sitz heißt das ich stecke jetzt 4 tsg
drais google für frauen
mit dem stück muss
sich
also sagen wir jetzt mal 45 sagt
bauer selbst alter zum beispiel wurde
von seinem stil zu boden geworfen
der hof wo alles geschah selbst alte
berichtet sein stil sei schon immer ein
übel launiges und unberechenbares tier
gewesen als er kürzlich stier und kür
zum auslauf trieb da sei es passiert
erstaunlicher sowie darf gegen
irina und ich bekomme ich hatte mich
eigentlich dagegen nur da und die
sprachliche gerochen und gegen
seit dem sturz aber hat stalter keine
kraft mehr in den händen gehabt dass ich
natürlich rechnen dass auch oder
verschoben ist also basiere korrigierte
damit wäre wo sie ihre sicheren davon
ahnt aber ich glaube da muss man die
zeit halterung stand da noch in therapie
mache
der stier ist übrigens beim metzger
gelandet
willibald arzt mit leib und seele
ursprünglich arbeitete er als
bauzeichner im tiefbau auf dem zweiten
bildungsweg holte er die matura nach
lehrte deutsch in den usa studierte
anschließend medizin
baldi ist seit 19 jahren glücklich
verheiratet mit silvia einer walliserin
silvia war krankenschwester die liebe
traf sie im spital dienst die arzt frau
manage den haushalt und hilft überall in
der praxis aus zur familie gehören die
14 jährige patricia und der 16 jährige
matthias der bauzeichner studiert genau
wie einst sein vater
baldi sagt die familie sei seine
wichtigste kraftquelle ohne sie könnte
er den aufreibenden job nicht machen
afrika simbabwe bilder aus dem
privatarchiv anfangs der 90er jahre
arbeitete hier will baldi in eine
mission später
[Musik]
zusammen mit einem weiteren schweizer
arzt versorgten sie hier jährlich über
50.000 patienten
pädiatrischen ökologisch chirurgisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ganze spektrum der medizin sei zur
anwendung gekommen sagt baldi sogar eine
beinamputation habe durchgeführt
daneben gab er unterricht
million silvia baldi hatten ein jahr vor
afrika geheiratet matthias ihr erstes
kind wurde in simbabwe geboren
das buch spital im südlichen afrika gilt
das prägende erfahrung im leben von
landarzt bald
auch bei den einheimischen von entlebuch
kann baldi fast die ganze bandbreite der
medizinern wenden
in der schweiz beträgt das ahv
pflichtigen einkommen eines allgemein
praktikers im durchschnitt 200000
franken in waldis praxis lagern über
2.000 patienten dossiers voll mit
geschichten von den unwägbarkeiten des
lebens
an die 40 patienten kommen jeden tag
vorbei alle 10 bis 15 minuten wird
jemand neuer ins sprechzimmer gebeten
beim hausarzt bekommen wir einen
nachhaltigen einblick in die brüchigkeit
menschlicher existenz hier eine winzige
auswahl aus dem katalog der leiden mit
denen menschen im laufe eines lebens
geschlagen werden können kopf abwärts
geordnet
zu den störfällen zählen ein splitter im
auge oder ein hautausschlag von einer
fasnacht schminke
geplatzte blutgefäße in der nase
eine grippe
das aber schmerzen wegen einer
zahnprothese
aber das holen aktien der staatlich als
kehre
einen unterarmbruch nun so bis heute
habe ich noch ins plus
muskelverspannungen
prostatakrebs
eine verklebung der scheide
ein arbeitsunfall
vor
hautschäden wegen schlecht sitzende
prothese
das ist dass ich gar nicht so ganz genau
wo sie meist mit rheumatischen leiden
ein verschobener wirbel
so
notfall ein 14 jähriger schüler hat sich
beim basketball den finger verletzt
so geschehen und gemacht und ich wollte
das röntgenbild zeigt dass ein gelenk
des kleinen fingers mindestens um einen
halben zentimeter verschoben ist
doch ein robuster dreister schock etwas
angst sitzt wohl in lukas eingeweiht
die
zähne putzen
jetzt wenn wir warten bis die zuschauer
nach dem stück um liebe wenn ja muss ich
die
so bestraften
da merkt man sie ihr land kennen egal wo
ich einfach der räder angeschafft muss
natürlich auch wieder hauptsache regal
aber auch zählte ein bußgeld
heißen der im und heiko
ziehen nach vorn und nach außen so wird
das fingerglied wieder eingerenkt
bald passiert
und dann ist da ja ja schon das hat
schon knacken
[Musik]
wir sind mit dem arzt auf dem weg zu
niklaus felde
heute geht es um seine 84-jährige frau
marie
es wird ein schmerzhafter aus besucht
werden
marie lag bis vor kurzem wegen eines
lungeninfekts es im spital entzündung
und fieber haben aber nicht nachgelassen
[Musik]
doktor baldi ist hausarzt der felder wie
immer misst den blutdruck kontrolliert
die blutverdünnung und hört lunge und
herz ab
was jetzt kommt tut weh sie erwägen auch
für den betrachter doktor baldi benötigt
blut und sucht eine geeignete vene
lädt das machen und diese dann nach der
partie wurden je
aktie genannt
ronny
kommt schon
handelt und daher nur um wann das aber
liebe ja nun nicht bewegt welche gene
über
eine minute steckt die nadel im fleisch
[Musik]
nicht der
die blutentnahme dient weiteren
medizinischen abklärung ob
mir leidgetan
[Musik]
nacht fällt über entlebuch
wenn andere feierabend haben wartet auf
doktor baldi noch ein gutes stück arbeit
es gilt berichte an versicherungen und
krankenkassen zu diktieren rapporte an
spezialisten oder berufskollegen zu
verfassen kurz bürokratie
bis zu zwei stunden papierarbeit fallen
pro abend an
[Musik]
babys häufige klienten in doktor valdez
praxis
ab zwei monaten kommen sie meist still
vergnügt und lachend im gegensatz zum
abgang
ungemütlich für die babys wird's wenn
bald die zur spritze greift
[Musik]
das ist verfügt york city waterfalls
gott dass der schock von der spritze
interesse über 100 hat willkommen herr
baldi sie sind jetzt 28 ski ist belastet
immer noch gleich groß zb nicht praxis
zwölf stunden tag voll auf trab der
ausstieg in der praxis während im
taktisch immer noch jene sogar wachsen
aber mir hat mir heute müssen erkennen
dass mir also nötig und wieder vor mir
waren die jungärzte
riesig seiner bringen und darum hat
mittelsachsen
neue formel
1 karriere war eben auch an vertraglich
verblüffung familie weil das wachstum
haben wir jetzt eigentlich ist könne
wesentlich entlasten indem man die teams
vor allem auch darüber dass wir noch
einmal im detail was haben wir eine
absuche befundene junger student oben
geschafft hat
ihre arbeit meine frau und ich dass ich
glaube ich nicht so die bilder zeigen
verantwortung hat bis vor es der mensch
ist in ihre gesamte technik und zwar gab
es elf die für die ganze bevölkerung in
anspruch ist ihre hand wie kalzium mit
der front es tatsächlich eine große
verantwortung aber ich glaube wenn er
gut die ausbildung hat
über die außen stand da wo man hat wenn
man also einfach gewisse das ganze
aufholen
ich muss die verantwortung trage aber
man muss natürlich wissen was in die
grenzen sind das muss jeder jedem beruf
die grenze kann muss einfach sagen so
ich habe ist total nach ansicht der
patient behandelt man muss in aller welt
auf dem zweiten bildungsweg arzt oder zu
stellen weil ich meine
das vorstelle was ist schlüsselerlebnis
weichen gestellt
dafür verantwortlich ist dass sie erst
wurde sind
also alles klar
schlüsselerlebnis hatte aber ich weiß
das nicht mitgemacht haben dass ich
verlängere mit verloren die richtige und
heiliger wähler nämlich die rein
technische wichtig weil ich einfach dank
dran ich muss mich mit mancher redet
merkt ihr ich bin gern kommuniziert so
mancher gern hat und mit dem biss wie
die macher und von der vag sucht was ich
könnte die sparte machen ich glaube
einen wichtigen schlüssel erlebnis ist
das ich sehen wollte biologie lehrer
kann in den mittelschulen und ihre
leichter wäre im biologie um um sattler
und detailreich des ordens oder zukunft
sehe und bereichen sowie der medizin
konnten das ganz krug aktuell und spart
dabei da und dort die bauherren sie
seien schon gewusst dass sie dann
wirklich mal russland aus wie zb nicht
so ganz nicht sie also ist nie fertig
sie von der notoperation
jetzt sind also fünf jahre vergangen
seit sie den dokumentarfilm bergsee hand
jetzt natürlich wunder wie geht das mit
zu unter http axxis vom drv die welt
erklären wir jetzt gerade mal einen
stand in ostdeutschland kennen
und punkt 8 wie immer auftritt doktor
baldi heute zusammen mit doktor manuela
rust die 39 jährige stammt aus
mecklenburg vorpommern in
norddeutschland zu sagen das reisebüro
besprechen
letztes jahr hat sie sechs monate als
assistenzärztin in der praxis von dr
baldige arbeitet
walde kommt in drei jahren ins
pensionsalter die frage danach folge
beschäftigt ihn
doctorow ist wiederum liebäugelt damit
in der schweiz eine land praxis zu
übernehmen
gleich muss ball direkt zu einer spital
sitzung derweil wird doctorows den laden
schmeißen wie wir gleich mit erleben ich
habe jetzt aber ihre alten bilder
angeguckt
sie sind letztes jahr auch dagewesen
helm januar genau
die ärztin lebt seit acht jahren in der
schweiz sie mag die menschen hier und
ihre sprache
parat wir können uns auch
klar sagt sie sie sei die dusche und
bleibe wohl die tüte
ich sage mich kennen sie noch hoffe ich
jetzt die menschen auf dem land haben es
ihr besonders angetan
sie seien genügsamen bodenständig und
hätten eine höhere schmerzgrenze
als deutsche mitten in der ländlichen
schweiz was hat sie sich vorgängig
gedacht eigentlich gar nichts also man
hat mir vorher gesagt
was du gehst du ins entlebuch und da
muss aber den logen und so aber es ist
eigentlich sehr angenehm mit den worten
ich muss auch sagen ich wollte ja
hierher also ich hab das ja gewählt es
ist ja nicht ein muss warum ein tatort
quartett wegen dem dr baldi natürlich
auch und die gegend weil ich das gefühl
hatte dass es eben noch richtige medizin
es ist noch dass arzt sein was ich mir
vorgestellt habe ja
roubini schnyder
hubert danach erst nieder sondern
kann passieren also wie gut es ihnen ja
auch langsam wieder sollte ja man sieht
eben schon nach ich liebe piece schmiede
ist alleinunterhalter für feste aller
art zur zeit plagen ihn gallensteine
wie ist es mit dem durchfall hält sie
wie oft am tag ungefähr
wie oft zu sechs mal fünf sechs mal und
richtig wässrig
was ihn als party hengst fuchs ist das
ärztliche alkoholverbot
bis auf den magen schlägt ihn dass er 24
tabletten am tag schlucken muss
ja
ja ja ja und trotzdem und trotzdem den
durchfall
dann machen wir
sie brauchen jetzt schon noch ist die
antibiotika das schon
das leben mit seinen risiken und
nebenwirkungen
beschert dem arzt eine gut besuchte
praxis aktuellen angebot sind grippe und
erkältungen
für überraschende dramatik sorgen
impfungen
oder notfälle wie eine blutvergiftung
oder eine halb abgefräste daumen
nach wie vor hilft baldys ehefrau sylvia
in der praxis aus
vier weitere frauen teils lehrlinge
dienen dem doktor zu
[Musik]
doktor baldi macht sich auf zum
altersheim
regelmäßig besucht er hier jene
patienten die es nicht immer in seine
praxis schaffen
[Musik]
gleich werden wie eine alte bekannte
wiedersehen
[Musik]
wir erinnern uns es ist josefine
baumeler die dem doktor jeweils eine
tafel schokolade zusteckte jahrelang
hatten sie und ihr mann franz einst
alphirten in einem abgelegenen heimat
gewohnt vor drei jahren wurde ein umzug
ins alter seien nötig
[Musik]
josefine ist fast 89 franz starb 94
jährig im letzten mai sein tod hat hier
sehr zugesetzt sie waren 60 jahre
verheiratet
weiteres unheil droht
[Musik]
ja aber entweder weniger blut im sauber
und jetzt behaupten namen für ein paar
tage später
aufgabe
neues erwartet uns im doktorhaus
rasche
transfers im haus
das war eine kleine übung zum
diagnostizieren eines vorhofflimmerns
mit simon schneider einem
medizinstudenten doktor baldi ist seit
vier jahren lehrmeister von simon der
hier sein hausarzt praktikum absolviert
frieda endlich die 82 jährige ist von
einer gesichts röte gefallen
simon ist 23 jährig und begeistert von
der großen bandbreite der
hausarztmedizin
[Musik]
gleich wird er zeigen wie genau er eine
diagnose stellen kann er steht im
zehnten semester seines medizinstudiums
nach rund 20 minuten ist die
untersuchung beendet
so
[Musik]
kohls rapportiert simon wasser bei den
verschiedenen tests rund ums gehör und
gesicht alles beobachtet hat so was ich
das
wenn jetzt aus und das ist risiken sieht
vor dass ich meine diagnose das gesicht
der easybell ausgehend vom rechten oder
das ist so sicher wie das
was wir diese woche
ja die wir unbedingt das ist das
wichtigste
das risiko eine bakterielle infektion
wurde von simon richtig erkannt
gut möglich dass sich simon schneider
der einst als hausarzt niederlassen wird
[Musik]
hätte simon schneider bös wo sie vor
einer im bitterkalten der medizinstudent
oceans praktikum gemacht hätte im herbst
die lizenz war verrutscht oder der
schneider wer übernimmt praxis dass sie
natürlich zwei verschiedene paar schuhe
uhr drastischen arzt ingo schon etliche
jahre erfahrung hat also noch im studium
auch im abschluss nach und sie waren
bereits vorher ausbildet parat zum
praxisübernahme und der simonsen acht
prüfungen rätseln hat muss er jetzt
einige ordner sind die sporen spitalrat
verdienen obwohl die type haar wäre zwar
bekannten der baby anja doch was ist
eigentlich wenn sie die praxis denn
erstens wohl weiter übergab meines
finanzielle spielt sicher eine rolle
aber was in der andere kriterien das
finanzielle spielt sicher weniger rolle
wichtig ist dass dass ich überzeugt bin
dass dir das die arztes frau ist zu
jener patienten dass sie gut ausgebildet
sind dass ihr top betreuung in einem
bild das ich eine für mich wichtig weil
dadurch man sich fühlt sich
verantwortlich war man so erlaube
patienten betreut als das abitur also
liebe gott herr schneider des
arztberufes
rundruf wie würdest du das dass sie beim
herr dr basis praktikum auch eine machen
sie den anfang vom studium ist eine
option wort aber man sich überlegen
später um eine landarztpraxis
option
ist
ja dass das mit dem neuen schema das
thema damit der vor ihm anfang nimmt er
das ersatzteil im durchschnitt verdiente
ein krebszellen was aus war es der
vierte launisch besitzt aber die
tägliche arbeit mit der patient die
praxis
mit main ist das mein job station später
auch die praktische fahrig muss sagen
und ich glaube es für alleine praxis
zweite buch man schon groß sie fertig
sein vom gefühl her ist es mehr als 50
prozent wo sie die richtigkeit oder
weniger gedanken schon mehr als 50 das
ist schon mal ein ausgang den
erhalt der stadt ajka
rund drei viertel der kinder und hose
pension das sind zahlen wo bekommt es
gibt noch viel zu wenig nachwuchs was
wirst du auch politisch nicht passieren
dass der berufe der attraktiver wird für
die jungen studentinnen und studenten
maschine muss dann ganz nah bloß
passieren also erst will ich sage es hat
ein großes aufheben das geordnete da das
als als landwirt schweiz zu wenige ernst
uns bildet und dann einfach die fahrer
wieder raus oder die falsche und auch
eine dem ausland importiert euro was sie
tun müssen es bildet es geht rufen
andere gründe warum so sicher weniger
wenn die cousins gibt sich zuerst sich
in fünf oder sechs projekte ich auch
nicht optimal bereitet mit der
potenziell und ein arzt aus account
sondern einfach die perfekte abspiel
rest
ist eigentlich gerade dachte immer nicht
mehr sein ich glaube dass howie der
letzten jahre als ob sie ist dass
studenten ihr immer nur für spezial
leistungs bildet worden sind die eu
setzt als professorin die gitarrensoli
und grünen hatten ein student im
speziallager gar nicht sehen was in der
praxis sehr schneider wie werdet ihr die
kolleginnen und kollegen über der burg
vom hausarzt
also jetzt verschiedene sachen gehört
das ist natürlich immer abhängig vom
hausarzt thomas praktikum gemacht und im
v an die eigentlich als extremes glück
klagte über einige patienten geschrieben
was als risiko
möglich 80 knopf das reißt zweiter und
auch ein patient mit das ganz klare und
die deren familie kollege schaut der
praxisalltag ist einfach so weiter wie
noch einmal um das natürlich so nicht so
optimal auf das praktikum beim fachmann
peter hook und einfach zu groß er baut
der filmische nach wunderbarer werbespot
für die prüfung muss man sieht mit
welcher hingabe und der beiden
engagements über die prinzipiell
gesprochene ab und das ganze junge
medizinstudentinnen und studenten für
den ratschlag oder wird sie
lustig machen auf dem kurs von busan
meinen
beruf so einfach sich oder so
interessant ist wir erweitern unser
beruf das ist sich einmal komplett also
sicher sein bis umfassen
man hat mit dem ganzer mann schwer aber
dieser ansatz tour mit dem seligen ein
als ich glaube es gibt kabul vor 1000 so
schön machen
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich und hoffe
natürlich dass das loch gestopft wird
das mit großem herzen dabei zu kommen
weil die herrschen heute weiß sie
das nächste mal gott die fortsetzung
folgt und thomas ulrich das ist der
berner oberland der fotograf und extrem
abenteurer
schlagen
2006 haben tür in russland beim
nato-russland-rat
damals nämlich will als erster mensch
fuß und der live russland über
nordkanada laufe das projekt ist
allerdings in den nächsten tagen
es ist ihm zu unserem thomas ulrich
etwas für verrückte plan hat er im
köcher und hädrich zentral vor dem
archiv solo auf verträumten immer noch
möglich das us-militär ihnen bewohnte
zum
wollten sind lassen
[Musik]